l'histoire en question oui c'est à dire
une histoire qui pose des questions une
histoire sur laquelle les historiens ne
sont pas d'accord et justement parce
qu'ils ne sont pas d'accord et bien
c'est la vérité qui paie parce que vous
et moi nous ne savons plus sur quel pied
danser alors dans cette nouvelle série
nous allons nous poser beaucoup de
questions et d'abord la première la
première question qui a tué ben barka
oui en plein jour en octobre 1965 le
leader marocain de l'opposition le
libère du tiers-monde
mehdi benbarka disparaît assurément on
l'a tué il a tué eh bien nous nous
posons toujours la question et cette
question je vais la poser d'abord à
daniel guérin daniel guérin historiens
historiens engagé qui a publié des
ouvrages sur l'anarchie survol à
luxembourg sur le front populaire sur
également mehdi ben barka et puis un
maître livre sur la lutte des classes
pendant la révolution française
daniel guérin qui a fondé à l'époque
qu'avec françois mauriac le comité pour
la vérité dans l'affairé ben barka
et puis je poserai la question à jacques
derogy jacques derogy gants journalistes
et qui à l'époque pour l'hebdomadaire
l'express a mené pendant des mois une
enquête que j'ai relu et qui reste après
tant d'années exemplaires alors nous
allons voir d'abord l'exposé des faits
et j'interrogerai ensuite mes deux
experts alors la question qui a tué ben
barka
29 octobre 1965 à vendredi
les français attendent le week-end de la
toussaint on parle de la campagne
présidentielle qui va s'ouvrir parce que
le mandat de charles de gaulle est
achevée et déjà françois mitterrand au
nom de la gauche s'est porté candidat
jean lecanu et le suit de près puis
charles de gaulle qui demande aux
français un nouveau mandat annonce qu'il
se présentera également il ça ne
signifie rien je restais la campagne
présidentielle est sain pendant la
campagne présidentielle que la sphère
benbarka va être découvertes par les
français il faut jamais l'oublier
alors voilà une 403 et 403 noir qui
roule sur l'autoroute du sud celle que
vous voyez n'est pas la 403 de la paire
bien sûr mais c'est une 403 pareil et à
l'intérieur les sommes que vous voyez ne
sont pas ceux de l'époque sauf celui
celui qui est à droite du chauffeur et
qui seize ans plus tard a accepté de
jouer son propre rôle cet homme là
s'appelle antoine lopez lors qu' à t-il
encore qui avait il encore le 29 octobre
dans cette voiture pour conduire la
voiture un policier souchon et puis
derrière à droite un autre policier
watteau et puis à gauche un truand à un
truand déjà nous verrons beaucoup de
truands dans cette affaire celui ci
s'appelle le nid qu'est ce qu'il fait
avec ces policiers est au milieu
sur la banquette arrière il y à un
cinquième homme celui là est un marocain
c'est le leader de l'opposition
marocaine il s'appelle mehdi ben barka
il est vivant dans 7 403 noir qui roule
sur l'autoroute du sud il est vivant
mais plus jamais on le reverra vivant
mehdi ben barka va mourir
et c'est la sphère la sphère qui
commence mehdi benbarka un marocain
famille modeste il travaille il est
intelligent à la force du poignet il
devient professeur professeur de
mathématiques et même il sera au collège
royal le professeur du prince hassan le
fils de mohamed 5 celui qui deviendra un
jour hassan ii le roi du maroc mais très
jeune aussi ils rêvent d'indépendance il
s'engage avec ceux qui demandent
l'indépendance et dès 1944 il est le co
signataire d'un appel pour
l'indépendance
résultat deux ans de prison et puis les
années passent et plus la dépendance
approche mehdi benbarka se lance dans la
politique c'est lui qui va négocier avec
les français avec d'autres le retour de
mohamed 5 et puis ensuite il sera
président de la première assemblée
consultative marocaine il sonde un parti
dissident de l'istiqlal c'est lui nsp
l'union nationale des forces populaires
et c'est un homme qu'on craint qu'on
redoute particules a derrière lui
beaucoup de gens c'est en même temps un
homme déterminé
qui va très loin dans ses idées et c'est
également un négociateur et c'est ce qui
fait sa force
jean lacouture a écrit un jour drôlement
et oui ben barka
c'est à la fois lénine et edgar faure
est justement parce qu'il est tout cela
on le redoute et il devra s'exiler parce
qu'il sait qu'on le poursuit et puis
rentrer un jour triomphalement le retour
de ben barka c'est un triomphe alors on
le redoute de plus en plus en même temps
on le flat hassan 2 comptera toujours
avec ben barka est à la fois hairaz ben
barka est secrètement car elle sera
toujours l'espoir de la voir auprès de
lui mais quand on fabrique un accident
sur une route marocaine
une voiture de police qui curieusement
accroche la voiture de ben barka
il est projeté dans le fossé il est
blessé grièvement il devra porter un
collier plâtre car une vertèbre
cervicale a été fait les et puis après
il portera une minerve alors oui ben
barka comprend que après cela ce sera où
la prison ou la mort et qu'il sera plus
efficace dans l'exil et il repart pour
l'exil cependant que l'on poursuit tous
ses camarades qu on les emprisonne les
gens de l'ump est en exil
ils portent des coups sévères au régime
ils dénoncent la curieuse guerre algéro
marocaine et là il est condamné à mort
par contumace
et puis plus tard on l'appliquera dans
un soi disant complot contre le palais
impérial deuxième condamnation à mort
visiblement ben barka est rayé de la
politique marocaine
mais non mais non parce que il y à une
opposition larvée au maroc et surtout il
y a beaucoup de gens malheureux il y a
beaucoup de chômeurs et des émeutes
éclatent à casablanca
quatre cent mille chômeurs à casablanca
des
le terrible qui font couler beaucoup de
sang et hassan deux se dit que tu mènes
vaudrait mieux séduire l'opposition
plutôt que de l'avoir contre lui et dans
un discours retentissant à saintes 2
annonce la mystique pour tous les
condamnés politiques
alors ben barka et bien benbarka c'est
du lourd l'homme dont on parle
ben barka c'est peut-être l'espoir de
demain et hassan deux n'est pas loin de
le penser qu'ils envoient à benbarka à
francfort son cousin et beau frère le
prince moulay ali et on fait des
affrètements rentrer et on veut on
confiera des responsabilités importantes
ben barka n'est pas loin d'accepter mais
il a ses conditions lieu il demande un
contrat de gouvernement de deux ans il
demande l'élimination de ces
personnalités rétrograde réactionnaires
qui sont autour du roi notamment dit il
des militaires des militaires qui ont
fait leur carrière dans l'armée
impérialiste et comment ne pas penser au
principal de ce ces militaires le
général oufkir ancien officier français
qui a fait blogueuse mans la guerre
d'italie dans l'armée française et puis
la guerre d'indochine et qui est tout
puissant auprès d'hassan ii puisqu'il
est ministre de l'intérieur oui ben
barka réclame cela et il y à distorsion
entre ce que demande hassan ii et ben
barka et hassan ii pour le moment ne
pense plus à faire revenir ben barka
pourtant benbarka espère toujours
revenir le jour même de la faire le 29
octobre 1965
ben barka confiera oui peut-être
peut-être vais-je entré et il l'a fait
louer un appartement à rabat et il a
préparé le retour de sa femme et ses
enfants voilà voilà le problème
il n'y a pas de doute que un certain
moment hassan ii a souhaité récupérer
ben barka récupérer ben barka pourquoi
pour un faire un ministre sans doute
mais est-ce qu'à partir d'un autre
moment quand on a su au maroc que ben
barka ne serait pas l'homme souple qu'on
imaginait
peut-être est-ce qu'on n'a pas voulu le
récupérer d'une autre manière c'est tout
le problème c'est toute la sphère ben
barka
c'est pourquoi l'homme qui est là dans 7
403 noir qui roule sur l'autoroute du
sud roule vers un destin fatal
le jour où on a décidé de le récupérer
je mets le mot récupérer entre
guillemets puisque nous sommes pas
encore capables d'élucider le sens de
cette récupération
le jour on a décidé de le récupérer 7 au
mois d'avril
1965 mais il y a un autre ben barka et
celui là on en a peu parlé au moment de
la fai la presse française a été au mini
bulle et par les fonctions par le rôle
de leader de l'opposition marocain
qu'était ben barka mais ben barka est
tout autre chose en exil
la personnalité la stature de ben barka
n'a fait que grande et il est devenu
l'un des leader du tiers monde alors que
s'affirme la réalité la puissance la
force du tiers-monde l'asie l'afrique
l'amérique latine
et voilà que maintenant partout il est
partout ben barka et le voyage il est à
pékin
il est dans les pays nouvellement
émancipée de l'afrique
il est en amérique latine il va voir
fidel castro il devient l'ami de fidel
castro et aux côtés de fidel castro
ils dénoncent l' impérialisme et
l'impérialisme il le désigne tout droit
c'est l'impérialisme américain c'est lui
qui parle et il dénonce aussi la cia
alors on n'a pas assez parlé de cela à
l'époque car c'est aussi cela
ben barka il est président pour le
moment du groupe qui prépare la
tricontinentale qu'est ce que c'est que
la tricontinentale et bien c'est à cuba
en janvier 66 le premier congrès des
représentants des peuples de l'asie de
l'afrique et de l'amérique latine
on n'a jamais vu ça c'est une date
primordial etc
ben barka qui prépare tout cela alors
c'est un gêneur benbaka pas seulement au
stade marocain sur un plan beaucoup plus
là alors oui on a décidé d'éliminer ben
barka et on peut penser que c'est au
mois d'avril d'éliminer pardon on a
décidé de récupérer ben barka et on peut
penser que sept mois d'avril 1965 que
l'opération a commencé mais qui a pris
la décision de la commencer à la mi
avril 1965 en effet un certain chute ou
qui arrivent appareil qui échoue qui est
bien on ne sait pas personne ne sait qui
échoue qui ça n'est pas son nom
d'ailleurs il est probablement chef des
brigades spéciales marocaine mais il a
d'autres noms on a essayé de lui en
attribuer certains on ne sait pas qui
est ou qui mais il joue un rôle capital
dans l'affairé il arrive à paris
il arrive à paris pour avoir des
rencontres justement dans le but de
récupérer ben barka et le 17 mai un
certain lopez arrive au maroc pour
rencontrer ofc et oufkir le ministre de
l'intérieur qui est lopez
nous allons parler beaucoup de lopez
d'antoine lopez dans cette émission et
nous le verrons beaucoup parce que c'est
le personnage central de la faire et on
peut penser que sans le pen il n'y
aurait peut être pas une affaire ben
barka ce qui ne veut pas dire que
l'appel soit coupable complice de
l'élimination de ben barka ce qui ne
veut pas dire non plus qu'il en soit
innocent oui nous ensemble
alors antoine lopez arrive arabe qui est
loupé un homme d'origine espagnole son
père est espagnol commerçants espagnol à
la force du poignet il s'est fait une
situation il est entré dans
l'administration d'air france et puis
ensuite il a été les délégués au maroc à
tanger c'est la tanger qui
la fait parler de lui tout a pris car un
jour un agent du sdec oui le service du
contre-espionnage est poursuivie police
espagnole et lopez so in extremis
l'agent du sdec le fait monter dans un
avion qui par le saut alors à paris le
sdec s'intéresse à lopez et quand lopez
est nommé chef d'escale à orly
le texte s'intéresse encore plus parce
que le sdec n'a pas que des agents
professionnels
il a ce qu'on appelle les honorables
correspondants ce sont des gens qui
bénévolement partout en france dans le
monde donnent des renseignements sur ce
qu'ils connaissent et le sdec en
l'espèce le colonel le roy-finville
héros de la résistance d'un des
meilleurs pitié du sdec se dit avec
lopez à orly nous aurions des choses de
premier ordre et c'est ce qui se passe
je suis des fils d'émigrés antonio lopez
blasquez élevé sur la zone au fin fond
de la courneuve drancy aubervilliers
depuis toujours puisque j'ai été là en
transe j'attendais le moment de pouvoir
faire quelque chose pour la mériter
cette nationalité française et puis un
jour compte tenu de mon poste à orly qui
impliquait la chose et des connaissances
que j'avais pu faire à tanger monsieur
laurent favre il me propose le show jay
hill n'a pas eu à insister beaucoup j'ai
dit tout de suite oui et à partir de là
j'ai été en mesure
antonio lopez blog basquaise de leurs
franchisés c'était devenu antoine bien
monsieur leur offre ville n'a pas eu à
s'en plaindre
lui il aime dans son livre ne dit il pas
que les meilleures affaires c'est moi
qui lui ai amené le dit il pas que j'ai
multiplié les informations valables qui
sont venus dans son service et bien
l'appareil est simple à s'en plaindre
alors précisément compte tenu des
relations j'avais eu à tanger je
connaissais bien mehdi ben barka
mehdi ben barka j'avais eu l'occasion
d'accompagner plusieurs fois à paris
sans jamais faire de rapport aux dettes
ni sur ses allées ni sur ses venues la
dernière fois qu'il a rejoint son
appartement de la rue lauriston c'est
moi qui les accompagnait par contre
quand le dec me demande d'aller au maroc
pour vérifier si effectivement ben barka
a été gracié pour moi c'est un signal
c'est que le sdec s'intéresse pour des
raisons qui lui sont propres à mehdi ben
barka et à partir de là je fais des
rapports sur tout ce qui concerne les
divines barca futur ministre marocain il
est donc hors lui mais il a des amis au
maroc
pourquoi bien parce qu'il a été pendant
trois ans à tanger que c'est un homme
qui rend service lopez c'est l'homme le
plus serviable du monde alors eux ils se
fait tout de suite des amis et parmi ses
amis l'ia ou spear
le ministre de l'intérieur le général
oufkir oufkir qui tutoie maintenant
lopez et quand lopez va au maroc et bien
il descend ou chez oufkir dans sa maison
et le 17 mai 1965 eh bien il est là avec
oufkir chez lui et il parle des deux ans
et au maroc lopez rencontre encore le
commandant de l'imi celui qui a succédé
à ouvrir à la tête de la sûreté
nationale marocaine de limoux et il
revient à paris le pas et il fait son
rapport hausse des coûts et nous avons
ce rapport reçu par le roi pinville et
nous voyons que lopez a révélé qu'on
avait décidé au maroc une opération de
récupération de ben barka fût-ce par des
moyens non orthodoxes c'est en toutes
lettres dans le rap
alors que ce que savait est ce que c'est
pour en faire un ministre qu'on décide
de récupérer un homme par des moyens non
orthodoxes je pose la question non
orthodoxes il faut dire que je dirige un
service qui a uniquement pour charge
comme mission permanente la recherche de
documents authentiques pour servir des
intérêts nationaux
je reçois des informations dans nos
correspondants que j'estime ne pas
devoir garder je les transmets pour
analyse et dans la rédaction j'utilise
s'agissant des moyens utilisés pour
permettre à monsieur mehdi ben barka de
rentrer au maroc comme les vite la
formule diplomatique on utilise le
rapprochement humain et le rapprochement
de main pour moi c'est pas orthodoxe
dans le sens diplomatique du gourou
c'est un orthodoxe
d'où cette malheureuse phrase qui est de
moins et que qui a fait tant de bruit au
cours du procès il est bien évident que
c'est pour mettre au point ses moyens
non orthodoxes que je tous qui êtes à
paris parce qu'il est toujours à part et
qu'est ce qu'il fait ou qu'il cherche
quelqu'un qui pourrait approcher ben
barka et avec qui on pourrait se mettre
d'accord il croit avoir trouvé surtout
qu'il y à un journaliste qui s'appelle
philippe bernier et qui est un ami ben
barka chtouki le sais et je tout qui va
rencontrer philippe bernier et va le
rencontrer trois fois et à chaque fois
il va lui proposer de l'argent beaucoup
d'argent si bernier veut l'aider à
s'approcher de benchmark une première
fois 10 millions d'anciens francs
une deuxième fois 20 millions d'anciens
francs nous sommes toujours en 65 on
parle dans d'anciens francs une
troisième fois 30 millions d'anciens
francs mais qui est philippe bernier
j'appartiens à une
familles de journalistes à trois
générations puisque mon arrière grand
père et l imprimeur de la commune mon
grand père a fondé plusieurs journaux
dans l'aurore et l'homme libre avec
georges clemenceau l'entité le
collaborateur est l'ami en ce qui me
concerne je me suis je suis entré dans
cette carrière dans cette profession en
1954 en prenant la direction des
programmes de radio maroc
j'ai par la suite essayé de conjuguer
les activités professionnelles avec
monétique de militantes la
décolonisation
c'est à ce titre que j'ai fondée en 1960
une agence de presse l'union africaine
de presse dont mehdi ben barka était
l'un des actionnaires est l'un des
collaborateurs
le tram itier étaient antérieurs je
l'avais connu au maroc lorsqu'il était
en résidence surveillée et j'étais j'ai
été amené à effectuer pour lui plusieurs
liaisons puis à prendre plusieurs
contacts que sa situation de déportés
lui interdisait de prendre cette amitié
était fondée sur une communauté d'idées
aux politiques l'homme l'homme était
d'une prodigieuse intelligence d'une
vivacité d'esprit remarquable et en
dehors de sa passion
80 il avait également la passion de
l'histoire et c'est également un
mathématicien et c'est je crois très
important pour le comprendre car il
prévoyait et il le calcul est l'avenir
le sien malheureusement eu les
chaufferies alors donc à cet ami de ben
barka
on a proposé beaucoup d'argent et on
peut se demander pourquoi bernier qui
est un ami de ben barka accepté
d'écouter je te plier bien il l'a
expliqué plus tard c'était pour essayer
de savoir jusqu'où on irait pour pouvoir
prévenir mais ben barka qu'un piège se
tendaient contre lui et il est vrai il
est sûr que bernier a prévenu le frère
de ben barka il a prévenu aussi un
opposant algérien qui était en danger et
qui s'est enfui aussitôt ailleurs alors
surtout qui a su qu'avec bernier ça ne
marchait pas et il a cherché quelqu'un
d'autre chouki of two qui était au maroc
en relation avec un truand marie encore
toujours un truand georges boucheseiche
à l'ancien lieutenant de pierrot le fou
il a passé plusieurs années en prison
il a participé à deux très gros coup
bouche sèche et maintenant maintenant il
est un petit peu à la retraite dans ce
sens qu'ils ne s'occupent plus que le
prostitution il a un hôtel de passe rue
blondel il est en train d'en acheter un
autre
a montparnasse et puis surtout au maroc
il est en train d'installer d'autres
hôtels
parce que là paris ça marche pas très
bien la police n'est pas très
compréhensif tandis qu'au maroc c'est
officiel la prostitution et même le
général oufkir veut en faire un argument
touristique qui revenait au maroc vous
trouverez tout ce que vous voulez alors
ou stage qui a de l'argent qu'ils
achètent des hôtels au maroc
il a plein d'amis au maroc et surtout
dans la police parce que quand on
installe des hôtels comme ça on paye
alors ils arrosent bruxelles il est très
bien vu
alors je te guide se dit mais bouche
sèche
et ce taux qui s'adresse à bouche sèche
est-ce que tu ne pourrais pas me trouver
quelqu'un un type en qui on pouvait
avoir confiance qui pourrait s'approcher
de ben barka pour ceci ou pour cela bush
je suis une omra non non non mais j'ai
quelqu'un très bien très bien très bien
elle s'appelle figon et c'est ainsi que
goethe ou qui entrent en relation avec
georges figon encore un truand qui est
fillon est bien un fils de famille des
voiliers condamné à 20 ans de prison
pour avoir tiré sur les policiers après
bien d'autres méfaits il en a fait 12 il
est sorti c'est le voyou type mais le
voyou attendant sa prétention
intellectuelle il a lu proust en prison
et quand pierre desgraupes pour cinq
colonnes à la une cherche à réaliser un
sujet sur un voyou eh bien on lui
présente figon le voyou de saint germain
des prés il a beaucoup d'amis écrivains
il connaît marguerite duras alors on me
dit voilà le type qui ira très bien
pourtant l'émission et c'est pourquoi
nous avons ce produit lieu document qui
a été tourné bien avant l'affairé ben
barka on ne pouvait même pas savoir que
fillon serait mêlé à l'affairé ben barka
et regarder fillon parlant dans l'ombre
à la caméra regardez cela prouve que la
télévision peut aussi écrire l'histoire
à ce moment là vous n'avez pas regretter
la stupidité au fond qui fait que vous
avez été en prison pendant plus de 11
ans j'ai regretté que ces cons là mais
qu'on élève attendra au vent c'est que
c'est à dire que vous l'avez rapporté à
ceux qui vous ont jugez par vous même
évidemment mais pas éprouver de remords
jamais ça n'existe pas ça n'existe pas
leur nom leur mort n'existe pas c'est
une invention de chrétiens et je ne
parle pas simplement des garçons qui
comme moi ont commis un acte tout à fait
délibérément je parle les types par
exemple qui sont là pour meurtre
passionnel on pourrait penser qu'ils
regrettent leurs actes ça n'existe pas
s'il y avait deux ou trois cents
millions hl en ce moment dans cette
pièce est que pendant qu'on tourne le
dos aux huissiers les prendre vous
feriez vous êtes beaucoup mais si je
pouvais vous assassinez pour 200
millions ça m'embêterait parce que
maintenant je vous connais que vous
n'êtes pas antipathique mais un beau
l'homme que je connais pas oui
qu'est-ce que vous souhaitez qui vous
arrive maintenant 5
c'est faire des châteaux en espagne je
reviens à m'en sortir d'une forme de
rachat finalement nous ne venons pas une
forme de rachats devraient pouvoir vivre
tout simplement quoi avec un peu de
pognon je voyais est sûre de pouvoir
sortir du tunnel sans doute obligés
d'aller mouiller quand serez-vous si
vous êtes sorti du tunnel dans les mois
qui suivent
si le tunnel le philippin normes ou y
aurait donc ce que veut figo dans la vie
c'est du pognon du pognon beaucoup de
pognon il le dit à tout le monde en même
temps dans le milieu
bon l'homme bien mais on ne prend pas
très au sérieux
on l'appelle jo le dingue ou jo le luff
on se demande s'il a la tête tout à fait
solide et c'est vrai qu'il est
quelquefois bizarre et puis qu'il a des
foucades clis
mais pourtant il a des amis beaucoup
d'amis dans le milieu il est l'ami de jo
attia le fameux jo attia et se targue
d'être l'ami de joie tiens d'ailleurs
tous les truands qui passeront dans
cette histoire sont des amis de jo attia
et puis il est l'ami de bouche sèche le
fameux bouche sachez puis il est l'ami
de leugny et puis l'ami de palme islami
de dubai des truands que nous allons
retrouver bien sûr lost ou qui vient
fillon qu'est ce que vous pouvez faire
pour moi ça intéresse pig ont du pognon
pour retrouver benbarka pour faire à ben
barka ce qu'on lui dira de faire
d'accord d'accord d'accord
et comme il a beaucoup d'imagination
si l'on est quand même temps une rêve
que le cinéma depuis qu'il est passé à
la télévision il a rencontré michel
mitrani qui a tourné le sujet avec lui
et qui même la fait tourner dans un film
de lui qui s'appelle le détenu et puis
dans les bistrots de
saint-germain-des-prés un jour mitrani a
présenté fillon à un certain philippe
bernier tiens philippe bernier et oui de
nouveau et ça donne une idée à fillon
parce que bernier qui a toujours
beaucoup d'affaires entre un rêve depuis
deux ou trois ans de réaliser un film
sur la décolonisation et bien
et voilà le pigeon dans l'esprit de
fille dont il le gâche tout qui bernier
l'ami de ben barka
on va lui dire que je suis producteur je
vais lui offrir de réaliser son film
avec ben barka comme conseiller
historique vous conseiller politique
comme on voudra et je te qui dit ben oui
mais moi là dedans
s'ils me revois bernier va réagir 90 ne
verras plus adieu je trouve tout et
disparaît et c'est ce qui se passe et
quand fillon parle du projet de film à
bernier bernier est ravie parce qu'il a
envie de faire ce film
alors il faut tout de suite allé voir
ben barka ou mais on est il ben barka
cygan ça l'intéresse et dernier le sait
il est au caire où il prépare la
conférence tricontinental bien le 2
septembre on part pour le caire et lopez
qui est un allié qui voit tout va les
voir partir mais il va savoir que je
trouve qu'il eut quand un autre avion au
bourget à une autre et au caire figo et
dernier rencontre ben barka parle du
film et ben barka est ravi bien sûr oui
oui je ferai ce film et voilà qu'ils
repartent pour paris et ils croient
encore lopez au retour
fillon s'est arrêtée athènes et il a
téléphoné à bouche sèche
tiens pour dire à monsieur georges ça
marche
la pa ay mort benbarka lopez ne s'est
pas lopez lui voit arriver et lopez
parle avec une ce livre et lopez fait un
nouveau rapport aux dès qu il ya une
combinaison curieuse qui est en train de
s'édifier il ya philo milhas bernier ya
tout qui est sous couvert d'un film on
est en train de monter quelque chose de
bizarre et le rapport est communiqué aux
dés donc tout est dit mais
ben barka voyage on attend qu'il soit
arrivé à genève on engage le réalisateur
qui est georges franju réalisateur de
grand talent souvenez-vous le sang des
bêtes
et puis on pense à marguerite duras pour
écrire le commentaire et il faut
présenter franju à ben barka qui est à
genève alors franju est d'accord il va
prendre l'avion dernier moment on
s'arrange pour qu'il manque l'avion
curieux non et puis fillon fera un autre
voyage à genève et signera seul le
contre avec ben barka mais voilà c'est
que lopez a pu voir lors du premier
voyage à genève
à côté du figo dans l'aérogare d'orly un
avocat s'appelle mettre le marchand et
lopez qui s'est beaucoup de choses c'est
que mettre le marchand c'est beaucoup
beaucoup paix de certaines opérations
alger anti aurès savez les barbouzes bas
ça existe et barbeau c'est bien mettre
le marchand et chef de barbouzes il en
tire d'ailleurs de l'orgueil il dit je
me suis battu pour le général de gaulle
il fallait lutter contre la grèce mais
enfin ce qu'ont fait les barbouzes à
alger vaut mieux pas trop en parler
qu'on ne parle pas aux français
d'algérie de ce qu'ont fait les
barbouzes alger alors on connaît la
puissance de mettre le marchand lopez de
ces caisses qui fait avec fillon alors
là la terrain difficile parce que lopez
jure que figo lui a présenté le marchand
lui disant je suis couvert et mettre le
marchand bien sûr dire c'est pas vrai
mais dans l'esprit de lopez c'est très
possible c hacun chef de barbouzes
puisse couvrir un truand comme si l'on
nous sommes dans une époque
et ça il faut que vous le compreniez
cette époque là est très difficile pour
l'historien parce que rien n'est clair
c'est une des rares époques de
l'histoire où il y eu tant de police
parallèle de services parallèles et
l'étrange de l'affairé mois de geôle dit
je suis encore naïf à mon âge ce qui me
scandalise c'est que ces services
parallèles fasse appel à tant de truands
c'est la gloire des truands cette époque
là enfin yal'affaire du colonel argoud
souvenez le colonel avoue l'un des chefs
de l'oas moi je n'ai pas de tendresse
pour le web mais le colonel argoud était
en allemagne les gouvernements décident
de récupérer le colonel à vous disant
que c'est le droit du gouvernement mais
qu'il charge temps de récupérer argoud
des agents officiels des soldats des
gens du ce dès qu'il ya des gens qui
sont payés pour ça qu'ils font très bien
leur métier
ben non on va charger monsieur georges
boucheseiche l'ancien lieutenant de
pierrot le fou je dis qu'on doit pas
faire des choses alors c'est ce qui rend
la sphère très compliqué c'est que tous
ces gens qui s'observe qui se voit d'un
côté d'un autre se disent mais celui là
il ne dételle police parallèle alors
celui là il va peut-être couvrir celui
ci ah bah celui ci on peut parler avec
lui parce qu'il est couvert par tel
autre et là c'est sale affaire mais bien
sûr alors donc il ya eu le marchand puis
à lopez et puis le voyage solitaire de
fillon inquiète tout le monde qu'est ce
qu'il est allé faire tout seul alors et
bernier n'est pas content bernier se dit
bon on va se passer de figure il va voir
franju lui dit viens on va négocier
ensemble directement les centres et puis
fillon n'aime pas ça et si l'on est sûr
y est voilà que lopez part pour genève
parce qu'il s'inquiète lui aussi lui il
dit que c'est tentant de l'agent du sdec
qui va à genève pour savoir ce qu'a fait
fit don mais évidemment ce qui est
bizarre c'est que lopez ne va pas seul à
genève il va avec bouche sèche et vous
pensez bien que au procès ce voyage avec
bouche sèche c'est quelque chose qui va
peser très lourd sur lopez enfin vous
voyez tout ça tout ça on est dans une
sorte marécages pas très pas très
agréable à voir et surtout à respirer
enfin ce que certain c'est que
maintenant contrat signé avec ben barka
que ben barka doit partir pour
l'indonésie qu'il ne part pas pour
l'indonésie
il s'arrête en tanzanie parce qu'elle
coup d'état en indonésie et que tout à
coup
il ya évidemment les communistes étaient
au pouvoir mais on va les chasser du
pouvoir
et on va tuer des centaines des milliers
de communistes une sorte génocide de
comme istres dont curieusement ne parle
jamais alors il est rentré à genève
ben barka et puis bon comme il ne va pas
repartir tout de suite on l'attend à
cuba mais ni repartira pas tout de suite
alors il repense à son film et il ne
peut naturellement pas se douter que ce
film ci pour bernier surtout pour franju
c'est une réalité pour fillon ça n'est
qu'une attrape nigaud et le mot attrape
nigaud est un peu léger pour ce qui
attend ben barka
parce que filon luis figo il a appris
aussi que lopez et bouche sèche étaient
allés à genève et il est surveillé alors
quoi on veut me doubler il a appris que
bernier et franju s'étaient vus sans lui
alors quoi on veut me doubler alors ce
qui l'intéresse c'est le pognon alors
quoi ils vont me prendre mon pognon
alors il ya une scène horrible fillon
arrive à orly fait une scène terrible à
lopez et lui dit écoute voilà si les
marocains veulent se débarrasser de moi
tant pis pour eux qu'ils me paye le
pognon je veux le pognon dealers aux
marocains mehdi lopez pourquoi tu veux
t'adresses à moi dit leur dis leur que
je veux le pognon sans sage balance tout
à la presse et c'est pas de la blague
monsieur georges figon arrive au journal
minute et déclare je vais vous raconter
une bonne histoire les marocains ont
engagé pour tuer ben barka
ils m'ont pas payer dans quelques jours
je vous raconterai d'autres l'attendent
et mon signal intéressant non et le 26
octobre
ben barka appel bernier à paris du tibet
écoutez je vais venir je vais venir à
paris le 29 alors on va pouvoir voir
franju ce franju qui n'a jamais pu
arriver jusqu'à genève alors à angers -
déjeuner chez lipp le 29 à 12h15 avec
franju avec dernier
avec vous bernier et puis aussi avec
figon très bien guy bernier qui va
retenir une table chez lipp et le 26
octobre ce coup de téléphone
or le 26 octobre d'autres sont avertis
de l'arrivée de ben barka
ce jour-là figon je dis bien figon
téléphone affolé 1 minute et dit ne
publie rien les gars j'ai rien dit j'ai
rien dis hein pas un mot bah oui parce
que le 14 octobre il était l 1 minute
parce qu'ils pensaient que l'opération
allait foire et comme on dit dans son
langage mais le 26 il ya du nouveau
fillon va également voir son avocat
maître le marchand pourquoi et puis le
28 octobre à la fin de l'après midi
lopez qui est à orly comme toujours voit
arriver qui chtouki à leur voyage tout
prix et qu'est ce qu'il veut ce tout qui
ils annoncent à lopez que le lendemain
le président le président c'est ben
barka l'ancien président de l'assemblée
consultative marocaine benbarka arrive
le lendemain et il faut des policiers
français pour la protection de ben barka
qui doit rencontrer d'importantes
personnalités marocaines ce qui n'étonne
pas lopez qui croit toujours à une
réconciliation de ben barka et du roi
hassan ii des policiers voulaient
trouver alors je taux qui va téléphoner
à quelqu'un du ministère de l'intérieur
français il a un correspondant dit il
pourquoi pas et finalement ne trouve pas
de policiers on se tourne vers lopez
l'homme à qui on demande toujours
services et lopez a une idée il dit mais
je vais faire appel à mon ami souchon
louis souchon inspecteur à la brigade
mondaine louis souchon chargée du trafic
des stupéfiants
luis ou chant qui depuis quelques temps
et le chef de lopez quoi quoi qu'est ce
que ça veut dire une épreuve dec bas il
n'est encore aux texans y être parce que
comme le trafic de drogue augmente à
cette époque là le premier ministre a
souhaité que
la lutte grandissent et on l'a voulu
envoyer à la brigade des stupéfiants un
agent du sdec et le roy-finville a
choisi lopez alors le ps travaille avec
souchon et à orly il découvre beaucoup
de trafic et souchon dira et pourtant ce
sont même pas beaucoup lopez souchon
dira il nous a rendu des services
inestimables tout le monde diplo pèse
fait des choses étonnantes à orly alors
depuis des semaines et des mois il rend
des services n'estime à blé le ps se dit
venus demander nous donner un coup de
main il appelle souchon et souchon vient
le soir du 28 voire lopez et lopez du
niveau là il faudrait que j ai deux
policiers roues par exemple vous prenez
un adjoint une voiture de la préfecture
et vous assurer la protection du
président benbarka lorsque l'on dit mais
il faudrait quand même que je sois
couvet et lopez a répondu à souchon mais
vous serez couvert vous serez couvert
parce que tout qui a dit tout à l'heure
au téléphone à son correspondant du
ministère de l'intérieur qu'il faudrait
appeler lui même la police et le
correspondant vous appellera demain
matin et il est exact que le lendemain
matin en arrivant à son bureau
souchon reçoit un coup de téléphone
inspecteurs souchon win qui est à
l'appareil issigeac aubert chef de
cabinet directeur de cabinet du ministre
de l'intérieur monsieur roger frey mes
respects monsieur le directeur dit mon
inspecteur souchon vous avez bien reçu
mission pour ce matin oui monsieur le
directeur
vous comptez vous y rendre oui le
directeur bon c'est parfait l autre
raccroche alors messieurs jacques aubert
bien sûr il y aura expertise contre
expertise
on analysera les voies et c'est sûr
monsieur robert déclara qui n'a jamais
téléphoné à souchon souchon jeux rares à
avoir entendu monsieur jacques aubert
mais était ce vraiment était ce vraiment
monsieur jacques aubert et est-ce
quelqu'un qui a joué le rôle de jacques
aubé là on ne le sait pas souchon a dit
quand on l'a interrogé plus tard
rudiments fab
comment lopez n'avait pas vous donner
des ordres et souchon a dit tout
naturellement b dû écouter
il nous avait rendu tellement de
services le ps était le premier qui nous
demandait et puis enfin c'est elle
luzech 100g que pour cet inspecteur ce
vieil inspecteur il est à la veille de
la retraite est bien cet inspecteur à
quelqu'un du sdec c'est quelqu'un
vraiment le seul but le quelqu'un qui on
doit dire oui alors bon souchon a dit
oui il a dit que le lendemain et bien
élire est au rendez vous c'est à dire à
midi devant chez lipp à et là ça devient
bizarre parce qu'on se demande comment
lopez c'est que le rendez vous et chez
lipp alors est-ce que c'est chou qui le
lie à dîner comment le cje shooking
alors là ici nous sommes dans une sorte
d'ombré
il ya beaucoup d'ombré dans la sphère
bon et le lendemain matin et bien le
lendemain matin 9h30 benbarka rivoli et
il téléphone à un étudiant l'histoire à
zemmouri en disant je vais te voir à 11h
ils attaquent femmes dans l'égout est
pris au rond point des champs elysées il
va porter sa sacoche 9 rue jean mermoz
là où habite un de ses amis anne
israélite marocain sellafield et ans
quand il vient à paris le rendez vous a
lieu avec une certaine difficulté au
rond point des champs elysées avec
l'étudiant et puis à midi on prend un
temps ci au rond point des champs
elysées ben barka explique à zemmouri
qu'il va faire un film
puis il aura besoin de documentation
historique et que lui étudiant en
histoire à zemmouri et bien peut servir
beaucoup il peut l'aider beaucoup
apprendre aux étudiants très bien lors
le taxi prend les champs elysées le pont
de la concorde le boulevard saint
germain
et puis alors ben barka lui demande
d'entrer dans la rue de rennes et de
s'arrêter devant un magasin qui
s'appelait qui s'appelle superbad et là
il fait le taxi
il regarde sa montre il est en avance
d'une parfaite à la mecque nous on va
faire quelques pas alors on continue
dans la rue de rennes on tourne à droite
dans la rue bernard palissy
on marche lentement devise on parle de 7
films on parle aussi de l'avenir du
maroc et c'est là que ben barka va dire
à zemmouri et bien oui moi je pense que
malgré toutes les difficultés je vais
rentrer omar ils n'y croient toujours
et puis on tourne à droite dans la rue
du dragon
et puis on tourne encore à droite dans
le boulevard saint germain et de
vitrines le libraire il est toujours en
avance alors une feuille et des livres
c'est un homme qui très littéraire
benbarka très intellectuel et regarde sa
montre bah voila c'est l'heure du rendez
vous on va y aller et là l'intention d'y
aller avec à zemmouri or là à ce moment
là chez lipp assis à la même table il y
a trois hommes il y as franju le metteur
en scène il y as frigo il y avait renié
ben barka est sur le trottoir du
boulevard saint germain
il ya d'autres y avoit tôt le policier
l'adjoint de souchon que souchon a pris
au passage il a dit tu viens avec moi
pour le malheur de watteau
watteau et souchon et puis un petit peu
plus loin le nid à le truand l'ami de
bouche sèche
qu'est ce qu'il fait là dedans et puis
il ya lopez notre ami lopez qui
curieusement est déguisé il a mis des
fausses moustaches il a mis des lunettes
qu'il a emprunté quelques jours plus tôt
à souchon pourquoi tu me déguiser
l'expliquera plus tard c'est qu'il est
sûr que ben barka part entre maroc
il sera premier ministre et puis lui il
sera directeur général de royal air
maroc qui ne pense qu'à ça lopez il un
tri postal depuis longtemps et dit alors
si un jour mais le barca me voit et me
dis qu'est ce que vous faisiez boulevard
saint-germain là il vaut mieux pas
qu'ils me voient alors lieu déguisés
mais enfin on se demande pourquoi il est
là il a expliqué que c'était pour le
sdec bien sûr qu'ils voulaient savoir ce
qui allait se passer alors souchon abord
benbarka sort sa plaque de police et lui
dit police monsieur le président vos
papiers et ben barka étonné sur son
passeport que sous son regard et lui
rend son passeport ce qui est
intéressant ce détail parce que c'est
pas une arrestation
quand on arrête quelqu'un on le garde
ses papiers et l' iran le passeport et
il ajoute monsieur le président pour
quelles raisons êtes vous à paris et il
répond pour un film mais n'avez-vous pas
d'autres raisons politiques que je ne
fais pas de politique en france dit ben
barka
mais vous devez cependant rencontré deux
hautes personnalités dit souchon auquel
nous sommes chargés de vous conduire et
là ben barka ne fait aucune opposition à
zemmouri lui affolée terrifié cet enfant
et ben barka et c'est certain il ne
s'est pas débattue il n'a pas appelé au
secours
c'est donc il croit cette possibilité
dans le contre et les hautes
personnalités et il monte dans la 403
noah qui attend là dans la contre-allée
alors monte pour conduire la voiture
souchon derrière ben barka au milieu je
les dis voitot à droite le nid à gauche
et lopez qui monte dans la voiture avec
ses fausses moustaches
et la voiture
[Musique]
qui parle qui s'engagent dans la rue de
rennes
la rue du château l'avenue du maine la
porte de châtillon l'autoroute
autoroutes du sud le silence lopez ne
dit pas un mot
on sort par la sortie de même si qui
n'existe plus aujourd'hui ensuite ses
licences huit semaines ici ensuite
fontenay le vicomte et on s'arrête
devant la maison de bouche sèche et oui
notre ami georges boucheseiche monsieur
jo à une belle maison là à fontenay le
vicomte où il reçoit ses amis et lada
fontenay-le-vicomte d'ailleurs il a
participé à la lutte contre l'ol c'est
pourquoi monsieur georges a toujours sa
carte tricolore est là monsieur georges
reçoit belle barque avec respect et le
conduit chez liszt cependant que l'open
souche on remonte dans la voiture repart
pour paris à partir de ce moment là plus
personne à part quelques-uns ne pourra
dire avec certitude ce qu'est devenu ben
barque
quant à lopez il est allaité le connais
pas loin de la rue des saints-pères un
club le club des vieux de la vieille il
affirme qu'il a téléphoné aux dec pour
avertir que le rendez vous est à
fontenay le vicomte le roy-finville
hausse des cas affirment que jamais
lopez n'a laissé de message
lopez est partie chez lui
il est épuisé parce qu'il n'a pas dormi
il était de service de nuit
il a faim il mangeait à ce moment là il
reçoit un coup de téléphone de bouche
sèche qui lui dit bien il faudrait que
tu viennes me chercher parce que j'ai
reçu un coup de téléphone de l'imi à
l'imi oui de l'imi la rime du maroc et
c'est normal dans l'esprit de lopez
puisque ben barka doit rencontrer une
autre personnalité marocaine ça doit
être lui alors lopez va chercher bouche
sèche chez lui le conduit à orly et puis
là on attend l'avion du maroc qui a
personne alors bouche sèche
s'impatienter dimanche à quoi c'est une
blague ou quoi ai-je faut appeler de
lyme
et lopez va à la cabine téléphonique la
plus voisine parce que bouche sèche il
est dur d'oreille alors qu'il n'est même
pas téléphoné puis alors il est trop
gros pour entrer dans une cabine
téléphonique alors lopez et là il
téléphone chez de l'imi à la sûreté
nationale ont dit mais n'est pas là dix
mille et alger tiens bizarre alors lopez
appel oufkir son ami oufkir et on lui
répond non il est pas là il vous
appellera si besoin les alors le fais
rentrer chez lui et le soir en effet
ouvrir à peine tu as appelé pourquoi et
bien parce que el kolli et chez monsieur
georges el kolli c'est le pseudonyme de
ben barka el kolli le colis est bien
husky rebond il est chez monsieur nô et
dira lopez oufkir n'avait pas l'air
étonné alors il faudrait que vous veniez
mon général du lopez écoute il faut que
je voie le patron puis après j'arrive
alors dans l'esprit de lopez il doit
arriver par la viande 3 heures du matin
et lopez qui n'a toujours pas dormi est
à l'avion de 3 heures du matin personne
alors il faut croire que la discussion
avec le patron entre vous fuirez le
patron s'est poursuivie pendant des
heures le patron qui sait san 2 à 4
personnes 2 et de quoi on parle et
hassan ii
et ouvrir cette nuit là ce n'est que le
lendemain matin que le frère de ben
barka les amis de ben barka alerterons
les autorités les journaux la machine
policière se mettra en marche mais
lentement
quant à lopez lui l'état or pour
recevoir des lignes qui arrive à midi et
il est à orly pour recevoir oufkir qui
arrive à 14h ou pire qu'il conduit dans
sa voiture ou dont on veut aller
ouf qui est bien à fontenay le vicomte
chez monsieur jo chez georges
boucheseiche dit bonne bouche
le ministre de l'intérieur du maroc et
dans la voiture où ce qui est dit à
lopez il faut que tu me prêtes à maison
pour demain cette nuit à bondy lopez mon
général ya 15 ans lui c'est que je suis
pas là moi cette nuit c'est le week-end
de la toussaint je conduis ma famille
non loire et ça ne fait rien dit ou fkir
prête moi ta maison et lopez lui dit ben
vous aurez les clés mon général
et il le conduit chez bouche sèche où il
laisse que va faire ouf kirsch et bouche
sèche et en effet le produit sa famille
dans le loiret notre ami lopez et puis
quand il entend à la radio il est à
peine arrivée europe 1 qui annonce
l'enlèvement de ben barka
il revient il va chez bouche sèche
personnes et puis il arrive chez lui à
ormoy et là le salon est allumée et il
s'aperçoit qu'il y à beaucoup de monde
dans son salon et qu'il y à là offrir
limites
et puis ces messieurs les crues en
bouche sèche
dubai pallice le nie tout le monde est
là et de quoi parle-t-on ben lopez dira
qu'il ne le sait pas parce qu'il est
allé se coucher et puis alors il se
passe des choses dans la nuit dont il se
souvient mal des allées et venues
qu'elle allait
nu et puis finalement le lendemain matin
alors qu'il dort à poings fermés
il a dû se relever pendant la nuit enfin
il lui arrive d'état d'aventura lopez
est à 5 heures du matin alors qu'il dort
encore eh bien on vient de réveiller il
faut qu'ils conduisent ou ski à orly
avec guy nous nous sommes maintenant le
2 novembre
hélas le 2 novembre fillon se présente
chez son avocat maître le marchand et
lui raconte ce qui s'est passé et que
dit fillon et bien oui oufkir est arrivé
là bas
ben barka ba on l'avait tenu de force
et puis quand ouvrir est arrivé il est
allé chercher un poignard à la panoplie
qui avait dans l'entrée de chez bouche
sèche et puis alors là avec le poignard
bon bah oufkir ce n'était pas joli ce
qu'il a fait de ben barka abel n'était
pas encore mort bnda alors au moment où
on allait le finir bonne bonne bouche il
est dit pas ici
ah non pas ici alors ouvrir il a dit ben
voilà qu'elle met dans une voiture on va
chez lopez jeu les clés alors on est
tous allés chez lopez alors là il est on
l'a descendue dans la cave
le bnd barque car on l'a attaché aux
tuyaux du chauffage central
bon ben alors là c'est là qu'il est mort
voilà le récite fillon qui sera
d'ailleurs reproduit à quelques
différences près plus tard dans la
presse et le marchand va appeler le
commissaire caillots auquel il est lié
pour le raconter tout et le commissaire
caille va déjeuner avec le roi fin ville
essayez de savoir ce que le d'excès de
cette affaire
mais qu'y at il devrait dans le récit de
file ont en fait on n'en sait rien
faut-il prendre au sérieux le récit d'un
truand wii est véritablement cette
triste affaire ben barka commence pour
moi le 2
je ne suis mêlé en rien dans cette
affaire
j'ignore tout des tenants et des
aboutissants et pourtant je vais faire
117 jours de prison dans les prisons
françaises
alors quand je réfléchis un peu au
déroulement de tous au procès et toute
l'instruction surtout je me pose des
questions
pourquoi pourquoi un fonctionnaire un
chef de service d'un service que j'aime
beaucoup et qui est un grand service
français a pu abandonner l'un des siens
est-ce qu'à l'époque je dérangeais
est-ce que j'étais à mon tour non
orthodoxes c'est bien possible
seulement je ne peux pas l'oublier
et si je continue à chercher c'est un
peu cette raison le procès s'est déroulé
deux fois trois mois c'est quand même et
l'homme at on trouvé at-on véritablement
sanctionner les coupables
je me pose la question
le 3 novembre souchon va tout avoué au
directeur de la police judiciaire et
lopez confiera tout ce qu'il sait de la
faire en demandant que son appartenance
aux dec ne soit pas avoué dans le procès
verbal et 7 abstentions sera grave de
conséquences la police sait maintenant
en action on va fontenay-le-vicomte on
cherche partout le cadavre de ben barka
on fouille dans l'essonne on fouille
dans les étangs voisins on va à ormoy
chez lopez on va dans la cave on passe
la cave au peigne fin
on ne trouve pas de traces des experts
cherchent mais il n'y a aucune trace de
lien qui aurait été attaché aux tuyaux
du chauffage central et les chiens
policiers ne trouve rien
mais ça y est c'est parti la sphère
s'emballe tous les journaux ne parlent
que de cela le scandale
le scandale le scandale et c'est en
pleine campagne présidentielle et c'est
le scandale de la vème république
chaque république à son scandale alors
le lendemain on se réunit au sommet le
premier ministre
pompidou roger frey couve de murville
ministre des affaires étrangères et on
décide d'essayer de retrouver ben barka
sans se brouiller avec le maroc est de
faire des démarches auprès du maroc pour
qu'on aide la police française dans l'
enquête et c'est pour ça qu'on n'arrête
pas souchon et watteau tout de suite
parce que si on les arrêter eh bien le
maroc pourrait dire eh bien voyez sont
des policiers français qui l'ont arrêté
ben barka
c'est une affaire française et c'est
seulement quand on s'aperçoit que le
maroc on en a aucun secours attendent
qu'on l'arrêtera souchon et voitot dix
jours plus tard au milieu du scandale
une voix allait se faire entendre une
voix
évidemment que la france que le monde
attendait celle du général de gaulle ce
qui s'est passé n'a rien eu que de
vulgaires et de subalterne
il s'est agi d'une opération consistant
à amener benbarka au contact d'ouvrir et
de ses assistants en un lieu propice au
règlement de leurs comptes cette
opération aidés par des hommes à toute
main il ya toute aventure dont l'un
s'est suicidé depuis a été cette
opération a été préparée et organisée
par un indicateur du service de contre
espionnage français à la faveur du
silence observé par le chef d'études qui
l'employait l'indicateur en question
ayant trouvé le concours
deux policiers avec lesquels il était en
rapports fréquents pour des raisons de
service mais rien absolument rien
n'indique que le contre espionnage et la
police en tant que tel dans leur
ensemble est connue l'opération et à
plus forte raison qu'il est couvert au
contraire alors il va y avoir procès on
va inculper le roy-finville qu'il est
coupable de rien on va inculper bernier
ont vaincu le p souchon voitot lopez
bien sûr et puis de l'imi et puis aux
tirs et le procès va se plaider pendant
des semaines et pendant des mois
et puis plus personne n'y comprendra
rien les avocats s'empoigneront avec la
partie civile avec l'accusation les
témoins s'affronteront à la barre
jusqu'au jour où tout à coup de lime y
arrive du maroc et weeds leamy pourquoi
je veux défendre l'honneur de mon roi
l'honneur du général oufkir l'eau lors
du maroc et de limiers dans le box des
accusés et le procès reprend et on n'y
comprend pas davantage
y a pas un français jean jurés qui
continuent à lire en ce temps là les
comptes rendus d'audience la sphère ben
barka s'évanouissaient dans l'ennui et
puis un beau jour on l'a publié le
verdict
et voilà ce qui attendait tous ces
hommes
[Musique]
mais qu'ils étaient est condamné ou non
l'avis de tous ces hommes avaient changé
et aujourd'hui encore j'ai revu tous ses
protagonistes
il porte encore le poids de la sphère
benbarka sans savoir sans savoir
vraiment ce qui s'est passé ils
cherchent tous ces hommes
personne jusqu'à présent n'a réussi à le
sortir de concours de circonstances
connues pour aller plus loin savoir à
quel niveau de complicité de
responsabilité les assassins de ben
barka ont travaillé de quelconque liste
ils ont bénéficié comment il est mort
comment il a été torturé
voilà un homme à qui l'on a volé je
crois sa mort que s'est il passé
aujourd'hui je suis en mesure de le dire
et je vais faire une demande de révision
il y a quelques années un avocat célèbre
m'avait indiqué que mes éléments étaient
irréfutables
nous n'avons pas fait la demande de
révision à ce moment là parce qu'elle
risquait de tomber en désuétude
aujourd'hui nous pouvons l'obtenir et
nous la demandons pour découvrir la
vérité pour ma famille pour moi c'est
périmé pour la famille de mehdi ben
barka et pour tous les amis qui ont
toujours continué à croire en moi
nous découvrirons la vérité grâce à
cette demande de révision pour repartir
à zéro
on doit bien imaginer que cette
lamentable affaire a changé complètement
dans l'existence j'ai souffert au sein
de la famille et auprès des miens et
personne ne sera étonné
que je cherche je cherche je cherche et
je trouverais et je trouverai le jour où
j'aurai trouvé ainsi que je les produits
je l'écrirai alors qui a tué ben barka
il y aurait peut-être les truands qui
pourrait nous le dire aujourd'hui
mais que sont ils devenus figon figon et
bien fillon a été curieusement laissé en
liberté
pendant des semaines est ce que fit don
gêné est ce qu'il ne fallait que fillon
ne parle pas il s'est même fait
photographier dans paris devant le quai
des orfèvres ailleurs chaque semaine ont
publié une interview de figues dans les
hebdomadaires et puis un jour on l'a
trouvé mort dans son studio de la rue
des renault suicides ont dit les experts
et les français ont trouvé que c'était
un suicide qui venait à point nommé
alors les autres truands que sont ils
devenus bouche sèche le nid du bail
pallice il pourrait parler nous éclairer
eux ils savent bien ils se sont réfugiés
au maroc monsieur georges boucheseiche
dit bonne bouche est parti le lendemain
de la sphère à 9 heures pour le maroc
les autres ont suivi
et ils ont vécu au maroc pendant un
certain temps tant que offrir avec lui
puis ouvrir à lui-même comploter contre
son roi suicide
tout le monde sait suicide quand il le
faut dans cette affaire et d'un seul
coup la protection disparaît et on
arrête les truands sauf pallice parce
qu'il a un cancer et qu'il va mourir
mais les autres sont a été jeté en
prison semble t'il torturé ils sont
morts comme des chiens là dans des
prisons payant sans doute leur crime
mais ne parlons pas et on ne tenait pas
non plus à ce qu'il parle alors la
question toujours encore qui a tué ben
barka
qui a tué ben barka nous avons posé la
question plusieurs fois au cours de
cette émission et l'instant est venu de
tenter de répondre s'il est possible de
répondre ce qui n'est pas sûr vous avez
vu que les protagonistes même sauf un
lopez avoue ne pas savoir après tant
d'années alors depuis 1965 daniel guérin
aussi bien que jacques derogy se pose la
question jacques derogy en tant que
journaliste vous avez été très loin dans
la recherche sur cette affaire
aujourd'hui à quelle conclusion êtes
vous parvenu mais avec le recul du temps
et l'apaisement des passions je me
demande si la version donnée par le
général de gaulle dans sa conférence de
presse version que je passe à tort pour
avoir combattu n'était pas la plus
proche de la vérité c'est-à-dire un
règlement de compte politique marocain
perpétrés en france avec la complicité
une complicité subalternes française je
pense que de gaulle s'est trompé sur un
point dans cette conférence de presse de
ce qu'il n'a fait grief à la presse
d'avoir 2010 couler le l'honneur du
navire je crois qu'au contraire nous
avons tenu l'honneur du navire
précisément par un certain nombre d'
enquêtes que nous avons menées à
l'époque et pour ce qui est de l'express
jean françois kahn et moi qui dès le
début avant d'envisager l'éventualité
d'une culpabilité direct d'oufkir nous
avons été les premiers en parler d'elle
mois de novembre 1925
ensuite en ayant un contact avec fillon
et par une série de regroupements en
arrivant à reconstituer un récit qui
était publié au début de janvier 66 et
qui a fait rebondir la faire le fameux
récite fillon récit qui nous n'en sommes
que amplifié peut-être déformé peut-être
enjoliver les confidences que fillon a
fait dès les 2 et 3 novembre
c'est-à-dire quelques jours après le
crime ou à mettre le marchand et au
commissaire jean caille par téléphone
car le commissaire jean callas entendu
ses propos par téléphone et cette
rencontre ce dialogue en somme
cai figon le marchand c'est nous dans
l'express qui l'avons révélé seulement
au mois de janvier 1966 et
nous avons ainsi éclaircie un petit peu
la justice s'ils voulaient effectivement
pas un vrai je pense pour la cause avait
été de la justice et non pas desservis
l'honneur du navire en somme vous
revenez à la phrase de de gaulle une
affaire vulgaire et subalternes du côté
français parce que c'est pas une affaire
du maroc à cette barque parce que je
crois qu'il ya une chose sur laquelle
nous sommes tous d'accord à l'origine il
y aller maroc
on ne peut pas ne pas croire que les
marocains soit étranger à la faire je
dis bien le gouvernement du roi hassan 2
parce que tout de même par l'absurde on
peut le démontrer puisque les truands
pourquoi aurait-on fait mourir les
truands dans des prisons marocaines
si justement les truands n'avait eu rien
à voir avec le gouvernement marocain
daniel guérin et vous votre conclusion
après tant d'années d'études après tant
d'années long la conclusion rien à
plusieurs mais puisque la question est
posée qui a tué ben barka
je crois est en mesure de répondre sont
tout à fait catégorique c'est georges
boucheseiche qui a tué ben barka dans la
maison de fontenay le vicomte
vers 15h 15h30 le 29 octobre 65 en lui
assénant un coup de canne ou de bâtons
parce qu elle marqua avait cette sortie
on a empêché de sortir
et alors on lui a asséné ce coup à
l'endroit fragile de son organisme c'est
à dire l'endroit où ils avaient à 62 été
victimes de l'accident dont vous avez
parlé tout à l'heure
vertèbres cervicales sa vis-à-vis des
vertèbres cervicales et je pense qu'il
est mort très très rapidement après et
que lorsque bessèges est parti avec
lopez pour orly ce n'est pas tellement à
cause d'une éventuelle arrivée de libye
c'était surtout qu'il était pressé
bouche sèche de dire
adli miaou ski au maroc qui n'a pas
réussi à joindre ce qui était arrivé le
drame qui s'était produit mais comment
comment savez-vous sa dernière guerre
c'est la question qu'on se le c'est par
une très haute personnalité qui a eu à
faire avec le renseignement dans son
sens sa grande carrière et qui me l'a
dit je ne l'aurais pas inventé tout seul
je pense que le fait par exemple bouche
sèche a été mêlé a tant d'épisodes
antérieurs de la faire par exemple sur
voyage à jeunes
m du 7 octobre dans un bus parlais tout
à l'heure je pense que vous savez
vraiment l'homme qui a commis le crime
je pense que j'ai volontairement lors
c'est un accident non je pense que ce
n'est pas un accident je l' ai cru
pendant un certain temps mais je pense
qu'à partir d'une certaine époque au
début d'octobre
le pouvoir marocain où ce qui irait le
roi ensemble pas peu importe ont décidé
de liquider physiquement ben barka et
que toute l'entreprise a consisté à
utiliser le rendez vous à saint germain
des prés pour détourner ben barka vers
une autre destination
sous prétexte de rencontrer une
personnalité marocaine je crois
d'ailleurs savoir le nom d'une de ces
personnalités mais peu importe puisque
la rencontre n'a jamais les lieux jamais
lieu et pour cause
parce qu'on ne voulait pas qu'elle ait
lieu il restait empêche de bouche sèche
il s'est énervé s'impatienter il aurait
dit d'après les renseignements que j'ai
eues mais qu'est ce que je fais ici est
alors lui redonner ce coup et se serait
effondré voilà évidemment une
explication très importante je dois dire
que récemment
maurice schumann ancien ministre des
affaires étrangères m'a dit à moi qu'ils
avaient recueilli au maroc une
explication semblables que une
personnalité de l'opposition marocaine
lui avait confié que c'était bien bouche
sèche qui avait mis à mort même marca
mais par accident bouche sèche ne
connaissant pas sa force et on voulait
obtenir la fête
la version à presque semblables ayant
voulu retenir benbarka moment où celui
ci partait voulait partir nous voyons
arriver aucune personnalité marocaine
saison mais qu'est ce que je fais ici ou
est-elle la personnalité je m'en vais
dit ben barka et à ce moment là bouche
sèche qui est un colosse médias l'on
vous partez pas et pourquoi je ne
partirai pas à ce moment là bouche sèche
leur est un peu brutalisé et évidemment
ne sachant pas ou ne se souvenant pas
qu'il avait la vertèbre cervicale
fragile l'aurait mis à mort sans le
vouloir alors il ya dia au fonds un
fonds qui semble à bhl entre les deux
explique tous avec une explication une
différence très grave très importante
c'est que vu à mon avis était volontaire
était prémédité elles étaient prémédités
alors ceci nous amène à tous les
problèmes de la politique mondiale à
savoir que après la visite de ben barka
à fidel castro 27 septembre et
l'adoption définitive de l'appel mondial
et de la circulaire envoyée à tous les
peuples qui va retirer à la scène
continentale on avait résolu à rabattre
d'en finir avec la vie de mehdi ben
barka
mais alors attention on a lavé résolu
vous parlez de la tricontinentale ça
dépasse le maroc est ce que vous mettez
en cause d'autres pouvoirs que le maroc
je pense qu'après les documents que j'ai
eu la possibilité de publier et que j'ai
tenu d'ailleurs de la famille ben barka
est la partie civile
le texte même de l'appel mondial était
redoutable pour ce que l'on appelle l'
impérialisme américain qui était
considéré comme l'ennemi numéro un du ou
du monde et même il ya des phrases dans
lesquels on parle de soutien de la lutte
armée et on parle également de soutien
aux mouvements des africains de raids et
non des noirs d'origine africaine qui
vivent aux états unis
c'est alors qu'une incitation quelque
sorte à une lutte très violente aux
états unis même et je pense qu'à ce
moment là les services secrets
américains ont fait pression sur le roi
du maroc ne pas faire pression il
voulait pas décidé
tout seul évidemment c'est le roi du
maroc qui a fini par sous cette pression
décidé en effet il faut en finir
j'aime les roses j en pense et je pense
que l'objectif du pouvoir marocain était
en fait la disparition de ben bernanke
comme ben barka soit effacée de la carte
non pas assassiner n'ont pas tué parce
qu'il s'agissait pas d'en faire un
martyr facilement martyr d'une cause ou
de la révolution de l'opposition
marocaine
c'est proprement la disparition
d'ailleurs c'est le mot qui employait le
général de gaulle procéder à la
disparition mais je pense qu'il s'agit
du pouvoir marocain et de lui seul parce
que je ne vois pas cette conjuration
mondial des services occidentaux qu'ils
s'agissent de la france d'israël comme
vous le prétendez dans votre livre est
répétée états unis non ça je ne crois
pas du tout mais revanche leader du
terme ans louis vivière monde je dois
dire que parmi les confidences qui m'ont
été faites
j'ai su par une personnalité qui ne peut
malheureusement pas être nommé met
dehors j'espère qu'on voudra bien me
croire que le roi du maroc a lui même
confié à certaines personnes qui l'ont
rapporté que oufkir avait été manipulé
par la cia
le roi lui même l'a dit c'est à dire que
le roi intérêt à dire écoutez il a dit
aussi au début que c'était les services
français on a dit c'est les autres
je ne dis pas que ce sont les marocains
tout simplement je ne dis pas que le roi
hassan ii a dit à propos de la sphère
benbarka mais après la mort d'yves
kirill a confié oufkir était depuis
longtemps
manipulé par la cia aurait coûté la
disparition de marca pouvait
effectivement à me ranger les américains
mais entre nous la mort de ben barka ça
n'a pas empêché la tenue de la
conférence de la havane
ça m'a pas empêché le développement des
luttes du tiers-monde et des mouvements
de libération nationale
par conséquent je pense que ce qui
pourrait intéresser les américains
c'était les documents que vous pouvez
voir ben barka est d'ailleurs les
documents que lopez dieu m'a saisi dans
la serviette de ben barka dans la
serviette de chouki de ce jeu tout qui
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure à son
retour du caire si nous résumons vous
daniel guérin et vous jacques derogy
vous retrouvez sur un point à l'origine
il yal les services marocains
stevie a le goût vers le maroc est il
décide de se débarrasser de ben barka
je dis bien à partir d'octobre de
l'éliminer physique mais vous de le
faire disparaître
voilà voilà la différence de l'éliminer
de la canonnade leurs aînés le rêve
parce qu'on n'en fait pas un martyr
si on l'assassinât genève ou au caire qu
on en fait un martyr alors vous dites il
disparaît un beau jour à paris et
c'était un crime presque parfait sans la
présence de l'étudiant à zemmouri et
sans aussi le rôle de figurant dans
cette affaire est bien benbarka aurait
pris un jour l'avion pour paris de
genève on a vu passer à la frontière et
ils auraient tout moment et ce après ce
pas là leurs dix ans j'avais derogy vous
avez la même conclusion le faire
disparaître
personne ne sait qu'il est enlevée il
est chez bush tech la retenue donc ça
reviendra bien peu près au même
ils vont vous souvenez que dans les
tribunaux du 19e siècle président de
résumer les débats ce qui était
d'ailleurs très préjudiciable à l'accusé
c'est pourquoi on ne le fait plus je me
permettrait de me changer un président
est d'essayer peut-être de résumer et
d'ajouter peut-être le fruit de
réflexions que j'ai pu faire au long de
ces deux mois que je viens de passer
vous vous avez passé 15 en mémoire de
moi j'ai passées à étudier la ferme une
marque en essayant de joindre les
différentes informations je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous c'est une
affaire maroc à l'origine on veut se
débarrasser de ben barka at-on choisi de
l'assassiner officiellement ou
officieusement disons que vous êtes
d'accord on a décidé de le faire
disparaître alors qu'ils attendent mis
en avant et bien détruits ont là aussi
nous en sommes bien d'accord il ya
collusion très évidente entre bouche
sèche et les services marocains puisque
bouge tech est liée à la police
marocaine c'est par lui qu'on arrive à
fillon fillon dans le rôle me paraît
plus important qu'on l'a dit je vois moi
figo comme un personnage presque
centrale personnage qui a peut-être un
moment d'un effet capote l affaire dans
un sens qu'on l'avait pas prévu comme
quoi les gouvernements que je vais voilà
que je vais donner des leçons
gouvernement le gouvernement ne devrait
jamais faire appel à ces gens alors donc
tous fonctionnent très bien alors lopez
problème de lopez
est-ce que lopez c est ce qu il le sait
pas qu'il ait dit s'il ne l'est pas vous
hein pèse 105 il se reconnaît il me
traite avec amitié ce qui d'ailleurs me
surprend mais enfin bon mais je suis
persuadé qu'il sait tout et qu'il ment
et vous jacques derogy moi je pense
qu'il sait des choses qui ne sait plus
très bien où il en est la vérité de la
millionnaire ayant été manipulé il a
vraiment cru que c'était une opération
du sdec couverte qui seraient couverts
par le steak de même que figo a cru que
c'était des opérations us des jeux
j'aurais tendance à vous suivre en
l'occurrence alors lopez nous avons
raconté très en détail comment mais le
barca est arrivé là paris comment la
conduis là boulevard saint-germain
comment ils arrivent se bouche sèche
alors je crois en effet que c'est là
qu'il est mort dans l'après midi vers
15h 15h30
mais alors là je reviens fillon parce
qu'il ya une lettre dont on a beaucoup
discuté au procès qui est une arête de
l'oni tout cette rue on n'était pas là
et pourquoi il était parti bien sûr mais
le n'y a cru devoir écrire au président
dans une première étape on indique la
lettre était à peu près ce après on a
reconnu qu'elle était t elle était
authentique on l'analyse et le nid dit
dans cette lettre où il ya beaucoup pape
rhône a beaucoup pas laisser que gardant
benbarka chez bush tâche pendant book
sèche était aller téléphoner à orly et
bien fillon est arrivé dans une jaguar
et a emmené même barque
moi j'aurais tendance à penser que il a
emmené non pas comme dit le nid ben
barka vivant mais qui l'emmenait mort
pour mes dossiers le cadavre et ça
ressemble bien intriguant et qu'il
négocie le cadavre et pourquoi se
ventile se retrouver dans la nuit à
ormoy tout ce temps là qu'est ce qu'ils
font chez chez lopes le ministre de
l'intérieur de limites où les truands
soleil pour précisions et moi je pense
que dans la nuit fillon dit je suis à
même de vous fournir le cadavre
prenez le mais ce sera tant vous est une
hypothèse mais je crois que l'ale mérite
peut-être de réunir d'assembler un
certain nombre de points du passif
vérité avant de terminer un point
semaine qui manque est dans le film est
dans ce que nous disons maintenant c'est
le rôle très trouble joué par m le
marchand qui était non seulement
l'avocat mais le conseiller est l'amie
et l'ami de georges figon or on a trouvé
un document le marchand un questionnaire
politique
dont la valeur nette est indéniable
parce que c'est des questions posées
étaient très pertinentes sur les
activités ben barka et sur ses projets
d'avenir et a été prouvés par la justice
que ce questionnaire était de la main de
maître le marchand qui pourtant n'a
jamais été inculpé à la suite de cette
découverte est curieux c'est que ce
questionnaire rester toujours en
possession de figo et qu'on a trouvé
dans sa serviette après son suicide
je dis bien son suicide car
personnellement je suis convaincue de
suicide de filles c'était un chantage
qu'il exerçait en alliance est le
questionnaire dans sa serviette un
chantage contre le marchand parce qu'il
était persuadé que le marchand elle a
essayé de le supprimer
nous n'avons pas vu quelqu'un sur ce
plateau que nous allons découvrir
maintenant et qui est bachir ben barka
c'est à dire le fils de mehdi ben barka
bachir ben barka je n'ai pas voulu que
vous participiez à cet échange d'opinion
je pense que ce n'est pas votre désir
d'exprimer des vues sur un problème
historique parce que pour vous ce n'est
pas un problème historique la sphère
benbarka c'est votre vie alors je vous
donne la parole pour finir cette
émission que voulez-vous dire sur
l'affairé ben barka votre affaire
effectivement mon affaire la sphère de
ma mère de mes frères et soeurs la
sphère de toute la famille
depuis 16 ans nous cherchons la vérité
et jusqu'à aujourd'hui on peut dire
qu'on ne connaît pas toutes les
hypothèses qui ont été émises et qui
sont émises ne permettent pas de
répondre manière définitive qui a tué
mon père qui sont ces assassins et où
est son corps est depuis 16 ans nous
faisons tout nouveau ménagé aucun effort
pour répondre à cette question
ma grand mère est morte quelques
semaines avant la mort d'une rage de
gaulle et les mortes sans connaître le
sort de son fils et malgré les
assurances que lui avait données le
général de gaulle ma mère qui vit
actuellement en france à temps pour
connaître la vérité moi même j'ai déposé
une plainte en 75
une plainte pour assassinat pour essayer
enfin de connaître la vérité jusqu'à
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas réussi à la
connaître n'avons ménagé aucun effort
comme comme julie qui j'écris au
président pompidou 1972 n'ai reçu aucune
réponse
j'écris au président giscard d'estaing
en 1976 je n'ai reçu qu'une réponse
évasive
aujourd'hui après l'élection de françois
mitterrand notre espoir renaît et nous
pensons qu'aujourd'hui il est possible
qu enfin ont du coup la vérité sur la
mort de mon père qu'aujourd'hui on
pourra répondre que tu es mythe ben
barka bachir ben barka je vous remercie
je crois que tous les téléspectateurs
tous ceux qui viennent de suivre cette
émission partageront votre souhait
partageons votre désir je donne rendez
vous au public de l'histoire en question
le 10 décembre pour une émission sur le
thème la flotte se saborde à toulon 1942
[Musique]